oh is that a potato cam hey guys it's
Vadim Angelica and Max and welcome to
the unbiased camera comparison between
the iPhone 14 pro Max the s22 ultra and
the Z fold 4. now Vadim went out and he
took a bunch of images and we have seen
none of them other than this first one
and we're gonna be choosing our
favorites and seeing which camera is
actually the best so go ahead and play
along with us and this time we are going
to be awarding three points to the
winner two to the runner up and one to
last place all right so this is the
first photo of some simple French toast
breakfast right here it's really hard to
know without actually seeing this in
person that looks just too saturated to
me but who knows maybe that's what was
realistic that sounds a bit unsaturated
I think I like the middle one the best I
actually like the saturated one on the
left I'm going for that and then second
place to the middle all right let's see
and it looks like oh you guys both
didn't vote for the 14 pro why don't you
buy iPhones this is hilarious and here
you go this my baby Eli in his chair I
like the one on the left the best
because of the warmer skin tones it has
good detail and last place is when
they're right I think it's a bit too
cool I actually agree with you on this
looks like oh you guys both got the
iPhone this time two iPhones a nice skin
tones a z folds better than s22 next one
is my other son Eugene he just got a new
shirt from Grandma so his favorite shirt
I think I have to vote the same way this
time I like how that blue Pops I like
the brightness of the the face and the
skin tones and the one on the right is
my least favorite just because the face
is quite a bit darker than the other two
I actually like the one in the center
the most and then left then right okay
let's see looks like he has voted for
the Samsungs all right the next one this
is also with the main lens 1X wow I'm
gonna have to say the left one the one
on the right is so grainy this is tough
for me because none of them look great
I'm guessing it's probably a crop I
think that one's the worst because it
looks over sharpened in my opinion
um these two are close I don't like the
white balance here but I think it has
more detail all right and that was a 14
pro Max with the detail all right here
we go this is a portrait wow these two
here look pretty similar the one on the
right isn't as sharp uh but personally
as a photographer that shot a lot of
weddings I want the subject to be bright
and pop the white balance is also spot
on so that one's my favorite and that
one's the least favorite I actually
really like the one in the center I love
the the color of their skin the color of
her hair everything pops out looks
really good they pop out a lot more to
me compared to the background and to
this up here and then I would give
second to the right all right got the 14
pro Max on the left Z fold in the middle
all right this is actually a zoom shot
they're digitally zoomed in whatever
that one is it sucks yeah definitely the
right and then this I hope that's not
the iPhone it might be because I do take
a lot of shots let's see that's of
course the s22 this is the originals
this is zoomed in the 14 pro Max can
only go up to I believe 15 times the
z-fold can go 50 and the s2012 can go a
hundred how's the iPhone better than the
Z fold in our last comparison the z-fold
killed the iPhone 13 Pro Max with the
zoom shots but now this got so much
better even though it's the same exact
lens just better software all right
moving on to the next one this is ultra
wide on all of them yeah what happened
with that sky over there it's gone
there's no sky where is the sky there's
we have skies in Spokane that one's my
least favorite and then for my most
favorite one I think the one on the left
here because it's less blown out I think
it's less blown out I like the pop in
some of the colors and stuff I agree oh
the iPhone
it is the most detailed by far but it
got rid of this guy that was one of my
biggest complaints is the ultra wide
dynamic range sucked and you guys see it
here moving on to the next one this is a
macro shot this is minimal focusing
distance for Macro for each of them well
I feel like we have to vote for the
closest one for the closest one I think
right I might be okay with that yeah
this one has a lot of detail and it's
the closed captioning not available
[Music]
next one this is a selfie portrait so
the center one looks a little bit softer
than the other two however I'm still
picking it it looks the most natural
real to me and then probably the left
one because the right one just looks so
messed up from the cutout and it really
bothers me yeah I think I'm gonna have
to go with the left one first I like the
detail
um I like how the cutout is perfect it's
a little bit too warm I think I like the
colors better in the middle which is
going to be my second place okay so you
both did not like the right one which is
the eye oh so I guess unfortunately it
still has those uh cut out issues yeah
and there it needs to fix that they're
noticeable yeah it's all around yeah
just butchered it all right and this is
the next one and these are really
similar this is a hard one guys this
one's really tough they're so similar I
think for me the middle one is the best
I like the extra contrast I feel like I
see more detail as well the runner-up is
the one on the right yeah I agree with
you I really like the center one the
bokeh on the back is really nice and
natural compared to the right where it's
kind of distracting all right now this
is going to surprise you guys but before
I reveal it if you guys are Mac users
like we are who does any kind of work
with documents spreadsheets or
slideshows on your Mac software keep is
giving our viewers 20 off on genuine
Microsoft software like a one-time
purchase of Microsoft Office for Mac
which includes word excel and PowerPoint
now there are so many fishy websites out
there that could scam you but software
keep is a Microsoft certified partner
who sells only 100 genuine Microsoft
software so you don't have to worry
which resulted in software keep earning
over a hundred thousand five star
reviews they also have great prices on
other software including the most
popular antivirus software out there and
their customer service is phenomenal
with 24 7 365 customer support where
you'll talk to a real person instead of
a robot so if you have any questions
they'll be glad to hell so buy micro
soft Office for Mac or anything else you
need today and save 20 off they're
already great prices by using the link
in the description and the coupon code
Max Tech 20. all over team break it to
us we want to be surprised all right no
look at that yeah the s22 is in the
middle which I think has the most detail
yeah this time it's working so I haven't
got third place yeah for some reason
which is crazy because I mean this is
like as close as you can focus probably
or very close to it but that far shot
that we did before the iPhone one so
there's also lens differences not just
sensors all right getting to the next
one that's just a regular 1X 12
megapixel Bend now I'm not usually
somebody that votes based on contrast
but this time I have to say I have to go
with that middle shot I love the extra
contrast the leaves are dark Vadim pops
a little bit more warmer white balance
and I would say the one on the right is
the worst one it's just the most flat
they just kind of like blend into the
background absolutely
all right yep the 14 is in the middle
yeah pretty good contrast detail
everything looks good bricks all right
this next one is actually a video and
this is gonna be showing off the
difference between action mode on the
iPhone 14 pro Max and the super steady
stabilization I'm excited I'm excited
Apple finally is action but let's see it
wow okay
these two are not that smooth
that is really shaky wow can you play
that again I want a closer look here
play it again that is like nice contrast
so smooth it's super smooth and it looks
like it's wider too where these two are
punched in quite a bit more yeah all
right so which one are you guys choosing
well Angelica definitely right the
center's the worst absolutely yeah the
right center is the worst and yeah left
is second place let's see that was the
iPhone iPhone
so Apple waited a long time in at action
mode people complain that it crops and
it's not 4K but it's so much better than
the competition that's had it for years
all right this next one is also a video
this is actually comparing the Cinematic
mode yep that's video to the uh portrait
video of Portuguese Samsung yeah dude
before you play it that looks like a
photo right there all right all right
play it all right man that one on the
left is so smooth everything is so
bright the other ones are kind of
jittery yeah they're darker and it's
almost like stabilization isn't working
the middle one's the worst that one's
also on the right not that good the one
on the right is too dark to me yeah
maybe like it's not even HDR you know
when the multi-layer exposure with this
one uh I'm just surprised by how well
even in this spot right here look how
will that cinematic mode cut everything
out
I avoided using cinematic mode because
when it came out it was not good this
looks fantastic and these other two
aren't that bad surprisingly too but
definitely the left and the worst I
would say is the middle
you have the iPhone on the left dang so
the new 4k new 4k and HDR they added
they didn't have it it was 1080p knot
that is such an improvement and I'm just
shocked by how good the stabilization
that was impressive all right next one
this is just a 1x portrait somebody what
what color where has pants as far as I
know they're brown pants to me the one
the left to the right look like the
saturation was just kicked up a ton oh
yeah way up I'm picking the center and
I'll give second to the left yeah I
think so too uh Center number one I love
how he pops the sky has a little bit
more highlights uh the other two a
little bit too dark but I would say this
one has more detail okay Center was the
iPhone Z fold on the left wow so how
does this have more detail with 50
megapixels than 108. all right next one
this is actually Ultra wide inside of
building so it's kind of like low light
ish it's not super bright I really like
the one in the center there's so much
color so much saturation the one on the
right looks really cool and the one on
the left I'm not seeing as much detail
at all yeah I think the left one looks
like almost the colors are like
Overexposed or something I completely
agree with you Center was the Z fold we
had the iPhone on the right and the s22
on the left and I do want to mention
that it was actually white so the iPhone
was the most accurate and is by far the
most detailed but we prefer this thing
you guys prefer the other ones yeah all
right the next one this is a 3X regular
photo I'll just say that I really hope
the center one's not the iPhone one
because I like taking 3x shots and
there's like blotchiness in the skin
less detail that's the worst one for
sure I agree my preference is the one I
left a lot more detail uh the pants
aren't crushed the highlights and the
sweater pop everything it's so sharp I
mean that's the best shot all of that
detail in her hair when the center one
just looks so weird yeah let's see and
the iPhone was the one in the middle one
in the center yep all right next one
this is a just 1X regular 12 megapixel I
like the one on the right those knee
Neon Lights pop a lot they're not blown
out whereas these other two are blown
out so I think the second place is the
middle just because that's more detail
than left something that popped up to me
too is the difference in the sky
compared to these two oh that's
retaining that too feelings and stuff
all right that was the iPhone iPhone all
right next one this is actually a 15x
telephoto on all three of them wow that
was so horrible everything oh gosh but
that look there's no detail there you
don't know that's a wooden wall there
and this is what is going on with these
all blown out okay so the right one for
sure the right does a good job but
what's what's the worst place then you
would rather have noise or mush yeah the
noise is too bad I can't I'll go with
the noise because I don't like this
thing blown out all right the noise was
the iPhone the one on the right was the
s22 ultra because it has a 10x Optical
which the other two do know better yeah
you could actually see all the lines
texture tons of detail all right and
this is some kind of interesting story
pick the best big pickle
the one in the center pops out the most
to me yeah I agree one in the center
pops the most second place being the
left okay Center was 14 pro s22 on the
left next one we're getting to the night
mode this is a nice neon kind of sign
gelato is that way cool over there that
looks really cool
it looks it's pretty cool but not in the
getaway or cool as a gelato weight
that's last for me yeah this one's first
you agree okay Z fold four was the first
one left yep the iPhone last yeah it I
think it did make it a little bit too
cool in this scenario why is iPhone so
cool now yeah iPhone also used to be
always way too far looks like they're
backtracking and maybe too much they're
mixing it up all right on to the next
one this is an ultra wide indoors very
low light whoa what do you guys like
here one on the right looks so messed up
oh yeah flat flat kind of blotchy the
dynamic range didn't turn that well is
this a sushi place yes
I work for the left one because Eugene's
in it no I like the I like the fact that
it's not as blown out uh it's so like
dimensional while this one kind of
that's why yeah I think this might
actually have more detail so second
place but I still like left first
definitely the left was the 14 s22 in
the middle all right right next one this
is a selfie also pretty low light yeah
very low light definitely left and then
Center and then right I think you're
right this is like insane detail maybe
too much because the hair looks a little
crispy but I would still probably choose
over the other ones so the s22 was on
the left super super sharp 40 megapixel
right on there did a very good job the
iPhone was kind of blurry the one on the
right was terrible because I used the
inside selfie camera on that one
absolutely terrible you don't want to
use that one maybe they should have just
left that out all right next one this is
just a regular 1X 12 megapixel pretty
difficult here they're so similar can I
take like some of all three yeah
I like how this is actually warm and
even that's blown out it still pops
right yeah it glows where this is kind
of flat but at the same time this is
like too bright almost like a daytime
photo yeah and the one on the right is
too dark yeah and so that one is just
right a little more Middle Ground yeah
okay z-fold wow one this time s22 was
the worst in this case all right next
one dang this is actually using the full
sensors oh it's a crop Yep this is a
crop I gotta stay at the center Center
absolutely so weird Center almost looks
like a DSLR shot I gotta say it's not
over sharpened there's not that much
noise yeah
um second place is gonna go too
they're both pretty bad uh Second Place
second place yeah actually
it's because it's 48 megapixel that's a
large sensor and good processor and it's
raw Pro raw so this basically proves
that it's not all about specs and
numbers because the smallest sensor at
least in terms of the megapixel size did
the best it looks so far by far better I
mean look at that dynamic range there
too next one
this I believe is a 3X I think there's a
spider
there is a spider which spider looks the
best not
no yeah I can't even see it in the right
one that's cool
I think the right one it's a little too
dark but at least that glow pops out you
can brighten it slightly if you want
that shows too much background so second
place is gonna be left all right the
right one was the iPhone yep I guess
it's able to take the HDR of the glow to
another level yeah to another level it's
pretty impressive and this is night mode
on the ultra wide lens on all of them so
well the iPhone used to be the worst
yeah from before our previous code here
is so bad so I hope it got better
the what pops out to me is that the
warmth up there that's the first thing
that catches your eye it's warmer it
pops more you have that nice glow a lot
more detail with that I think this is
definitely the shot that I would want to
have on my phone probably followed by I
don't know to me the right one the right
one the left the middle one looks a
little too bright yeah I agree
the iPhone was on the line the crazy
thing about this is that it only took I
think one or two seconds for the
exposure for night mode whereas I
believe the z-fold took like up to five
oh the s22 was like three or four or
something all right this is a night time
selfie night mode selfie I've got to say
the right definitely the right the left
one looks
terrible in my opinion that looks like
it's daytime but not daytime yeah
there's no color to your skin at all
yeah yeah we white that one's slightly
better but still similar vampire that
one's Dynamic you have shadowing on your
face yep absolutely more detail and I'd
say like this uh ski and a highlight
roll-off and stuff that's the iPhone
surprisingly it did worse before it yeah
the front-facing camera is another weak
part too this is bit like basically no
light this was a tough one right and
this is a night mode portrait on all of
them I'm seeing a lot more detail in the
center but honestly to me when it comes
to a hair and face it almost looks like
it's pushing too far I like the one on
the right the most and then the center
and then the left looks kind of soft I
didn't expect you to say that uh but I
agree this is definitely a lot more
detailed the highlights pop a lot on the
sweater as well but it just looks over
sharpened in the face and in the hair
this just looks really like not lacks
the detail kind of Blends into the
background yeah or at least on the right
one there's kind of I think yeah exactly
okay
okay so the right one was the z-fold the
center was 14 pro I gotta say I'm
surprised that this is 108 megapixels
but it is so soft probably just to deal
with that much data it just messes it up
all right we got the next night mode
shots
is that a potato cam it is that's bad
too though it's better but bad man that
has a lot of noise but you can actually
keep that photo in your in your camera
you can actually look at you can read
the bottom too where it's here it's like
potatoes
anyway this is actually 10x 10x on all
of them 10. that has to be the s22 ultra
it actually has a s it actually has a
10x it actually has an optical 10x ahead
of time I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that
but which one is that the fold I gotta
say it's probably the fold over there
it's the worst that one's not much
better but at least it's better all
right guys all right you're ready
in the middle it's the iPhone
oh my goodness gracious and it has a 10x
Optical and I was shooting 10x not 9.9
10x the reason is I think it was using
the main it was using the main sensor
because it was so dark it was so dark
that it has to crop like 10 times 10x
that's why there's so much noise yep and
the z-fold maybe it did the same thing
but it is uh I don't know what a 50
megapixel so there's less pixels to deal
with yeah the iPhone wow do you remember
back in the day the iPhone used to go to
the wide camera if it was too dark
because the telephoto sucked yep but now
they're not doing it it's clearly this
is the actual telephone yeah it looks
like the other two are using the 1X
cropped in all right that was the last
photo 30 of them in total so make sure
to pause count up all your tallies
before we reveal who won so what do you
got well I'll just say the iPhone is
losing out first I think for both of us
yeah the iPhone was definitely losing
for me in the beginning and you know
there was HDR issues some other stuff
but then with the night stuff some of
the Porsche nice the nice stuff
um so how about you go first I got 66
for the iPhone followed by 58 for the
s22 and 56 for the fold so they almost
tied for the iPhone very close and for
me I had 56 for the fold for 53 for the
s22 very close to and 71 for the iPhone
I mean some of it's just color
preferences
um but the crazy thing is we did this
what about a month ago or so with this
last one before maybe less and the
iPhone got destroyed by the scene it was
terrible absolutely easily destroyed it
was embarrassing and I guess Apple
redeemed themselves comebacks the 48
megapixel was shockingly good in that uh
when you're shooting that full
resolution incredible um some of that
low light stuff looked great too
um the video action mode killed it and
the Cinematic all the videos so
definitely the most well-rounded camera
that's the only thing he gives maybe a
telephoto a 10x yeah next that's next
year as long as it doesn't look like
this yeah because it doesn't look like I
can't believe this this is crazy so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video and
Max is actually working on one comparing
the 14 pro Max to the 13 Pro Max and the
12 Pro Max to show the differences over
the years if you have one of those older
iPhones so definitely click the button
above to subscribe so you don't miss out
on that and check out a couple of those
videos right over there this has been
Vadim and Delica and Max and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]